it is October 13 2022 and you're
watching the code report yesterday
jetbrains announced the preview release
of Fleet the long-awaited IDE that's
been dubbed the vs code killer jetbrains
has an impeccable record when it comes
to building Ides with IntelliJ for Java
webstorm for JavaScript pie charm for
Python and so on if anybody is going to
build a Next Generation IDE to compete
with vs code it's jetbrains let's find
out if Fleet meets these high
expectations one of the main reasons vs
code is so popular is that it's free
Fleet is also free currently but appears
it will be a paid product in the future
to install it you need to download
jetbrain's toolbox where you pick and
choose the different programs that you
want to download through this app that's
a pretty big turn off or something I
would expect to be a lightweight
download speaking of which one of the
main criticisms of vs code is that it's
a big fat memory hog built with electron
now I don't condone fat shaming and I'm
proud to use the big and beautiful vs
code but was kind of shocked at the
amount of memory that fleet was using I
have Fleet and vs code opened up on the
same project the s-code is using about
750 megabytes while Fleet is using
almost 3gb diets they both require a lot
of CPU when you're actually editing but
I was very surprised at the memory
footprint here and check with some
friends on Discord to make sure that I
wasn't the only one anyone on Windows
reported more memory usage but on Linux
it appears to be smaller according to
infoworld it's mainly written in kotlin
and the front end UI uses skia with rust
being used in places as well hopefully
we get a ton of crazy features in
exchange for this memory let's find out
first of all I like the overall UI it's
minimal and approachable in contrast to
other jetbrains products which tend to
be pretty complex I really like its git
and git history panels and it also
supports Docker out of the box the
actual text editing experience is pretty
nice and has this next-gen feature
called find that allows you to search
for text within a file this is really
powerful when you need to find something
but don't know where it is because find
will search for something and then let
you know when it's found but what makes
split different than anything else on
the market is something called Smart
Mode when you first open it it just
works like a regular text editor however
at the top here you'll notice a button
to enable Smart Mode when you click it
it turns the editor into a full-blown
IDE with with features like autocomplete
refactoring and so on these features
require a lot more overhead because it
has to index the entire project so it's
cool to have the option to opt in only
as needed it's kind of like a hybrid
between a lightweight text editor and a
full-blown IDE although it appears to
take a long time like maybe over a
minute to index a project you can also
get full IDE features in vs code through
plugins but with Smart Mode it all just
kind of happens automatically currently
not everything is supported as you can
see here I have a spell project which
isn't supported which means no syntax
highlighting autocomplete or anything
maybe someone will create a spell plugin
in the future but currently that's not
possible in preview because currently
there's no API to extend Fleet with
plugins however that is guaranteed to be
a thing in the future that'll be pretty
essential because right now there's only
four themes to choose from and vs code
users are more concerned about how the
editor looks when someone is spying on
their laptop at Starbucks than any
actual intellisense coding features
overall I think fleet has a ton of
potential but it's definitely not a vs
code killer and I'm not even sure that's
what jetbrains is going for a paper
product will never challenge vs code
independent developers are just way too
poor and cheap especially with today's
CPI print which was once again worse
than expected I think the big innovation
here is that you can move indexing to a
remote space which seems like it would
be most appealing to large remote teams
where great intellisense can be achieved
on any language across multiple projects
but if you want to be a real Alpha like
the primogen or David Goggins you should
use Vim I want to see that guy who
immersed himself in [ __ ] hell and he
thought about quitting and leaving and
his wife and his kids and why am I here
is it is it worth it all this crazy [ __ ]
the way I do it is I open up my terminal
type in Vim then zoom out the camera a
little bit then take advantage of vs
code while Vim is running and now my mom
can probably say her son uses Vim this
has been the code report thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one
[Music]